[Music]
and baby now we got Drake pulls out some
new dance moves for the Apple music
promo showcasing his love for t swift
and acts as a PSA for why you always
need a spotter of course this ad has got
the social media world buzzing could Dre
ler really be a thing it comes on the
heels of Drake posting an Instagram of
the two of them back on November fourth
the shot was taken two weeks before at
Drizzy's birthday bash and while that
rumor continues to trend the internet
also couldn't get enough of Drake's to
grassy reunion with Nina Dobrev she was
on hand to deliver his award for best
rap hip-hop album his first of four AMAs
Amina 12 grasty together by the way so
we've come a long way you know
congratulations on all your success Nina
took to Twitter afterwards giving love
to her man Jimmy Brooks congratulations
to this popping badass love you buddy
hashtag Degrassi forever backstage Drake
continued the Canadian love posing with
Shawn Mendes and posting this pig with
the tags pickering God